- Everything okay with you two?
- You and me?
No, we're a mess.
We should spend some time apart.
(soft music)
- This woman named, Riswana,
I think I was actually speaking
with India, but anyway.
And she found a box of the old ones
and they sent them free of charge,
and their exactly the right kind.
- Wow that is a great story mom.
- Oh, don't be a dick, honey.
- You're not even
friends with Beth Chapin.
- So what?
You don't have to be friends with someone
to do what's right.
- [Elsa] Sweetie, hitting
someone's face is never right.
- Of course you don't get it.
When you were in high school,
you were the one picking on the fat kids.
- I had a pudgy friend.
Besides Bailey Bennett is a lovely girl,
and she did not deserve to get punched.
- Bailey Bennett is a twat.
- [Elsa] Card.
- What's going on?
- I have to cancel the Visa.
I left it at that bar after dance class.
That's what you're
wearing, that sweatshirt?
- What's wrong with it?
- Nothing, I just don't
understand why you do all
that working out if you're not going
to flaunt your cute little figure.
- Oh my god mom, you want
me to dress sluttier?
- Why are you canceling it?
- Identity theft.
Sweetie it was a compliment.
You're adorable under all that bulk
- Bye.
(door slam)
- Hey guys
- Hey!
- What did you think of the race?
- Great.
- You're so fast, you
were like a human car.
- Yeah, vroom.
- Amazing.
- You didn't see it?
- No, we didn't.
Sam had a major incident.
- He cut his hand.
- He was very upset.
- Honey.
- I bought these churros
with my own money,
so you can't have one.
Please don't ask.
Hey!
(crunching)
- I didn't ask.
- I feel like I keep
messing up with you, Casey.
- It's okay.
Don't worry about it,
Sam had a thing I get it.
- Yeah, it was a bad thing.
- Damn it, Casey.
Hey Mrs. Gardener!
- Evan.
Whoa, what a nice surprise.
- Hey, hi, yeah.
- We have cheese, help yourself, and figs.
- Oh, love figs.
- All kids do.
- Casey, this is a family dinner.
I've been cooking all day,
this is important to me.
Only you would invite someone
to a family dinner without even asking.
Sam and friends,
so many people.
- This is awesome.
- Zahid's my friend, and Paige
is just a girl from school.
- Come on in, you know the drill.
- I certainly do.
So strong, thank you.
- Well it's very nice to meet you all.
- Evan.
- Mr. Gardener.
- Dad.
- Why are we all saying
each other's names?
- Hey guys, why don't
you go sit on the sofa
and talk amongst yourselves,
and I'll be there in a minute.
Maybe tell an embarrassing
story about yourself
that nobody else knows.
We did that as an icebreaker
at Sam's camp last summer,
and boy were there some red faces.
(gentle music)
- Don't you think that's a
little el doobich, blunt, kush.
- Since its clearly bothering
you, why don't we just, honey.
- I'm sorry, what?
- I'm just going to take it off.
- What?
What the hell are you doing?
(laughs)
Are you serious?
- Yeah, great.
Much better.
- I kind of like the smell of smoke.
Reminds me of my uncle Rasheed
when he gave me sips of his beer.
- Oh my gosh, look at you!
You look so pretty.
Maybe different shoes.
- Mom.
- Honey, I want you to know
that I am fully onboard
for you to attend Clayton Prep.
- Are you?
Does this have anything to
with the five hour
closed door conversation
that you and dad had the other day?
- It took me some time, but I got there.
And the distance and the money,
and Sam, we'll figure it out.
- Honey you've always been
so mature and sophisticated.
You're going to fit right in here.
- Mom, I punched a girl
in the face two weeks ago.
- Honey they don't know that, okay.
Look, look at that girl in
her little uniform marching
towards her future with that big backpack.
That's going to be you next year.
Fresh start.
I got a fraud alert on my credit card.
Did you have to pick the most
expensive dress in the store?
(crying)
- Oh, honey.
I'm joking, I'm just kidding you.
(sniffling)
- I don't want to go to Clayton Prep.
- Okay.
- And honestly...
I don't know if I can
go because apparently
they found out that I
punched Bailey Bennett.
- Oh I know, I check in with them.
- Then why are you like telling
people that I'm going to go
there and buying me shirts?
- Because I think you're amazing,
and I think you're going to get in anyway.
- I'm just...
I'm scared because I don't
want to leave you guys
and Evan, and my team.
The whole Clayton Prep thing is starting
to feel kind of like...
- Selfish.
- Yeah.
- Even Sherice turned against me.
- No, Sherice is your best friend.
When you were little she used to follow
you around like a puppy dog.
- No, she was the one
that stole my clothes.
- She's a little bitch.
- I know.
(gentle music)
- Honey, it's okay to be a little selfish.
- Thanks mom.
- You kept the tags on right?
- Duh.
- Hey sleepy head, there she is.
I was thinking we should celebrate
you getting into Clayton.
Maybe go out to breakfast,
just the two of us?
(door slams)
Or lunch.
(upbeat music)
- Hey Case, want me to do your hair?
I can squeeze you in.
- Why are you even doing this?
You know Sam's not going
to the dance anymore.
- Well whether he goes or not,
I made a commitment and I plan to keep it.
- Oh really?
I didn't think commitments
mattered to you.
- I'll be right back.
Honey, I don't know
what's going on with you.
If you're stressed about changing schools,
or if it's something else,
but you can't keep taking it out on me.
I haven't done anything.
- Yeah, you're perfect.
- Hey.
I love you very much.
- Okay, whatever, I have to go.
- Oh Casey, good news.
- Oh Elsa, I don't care.
- Why are you calling Mom Elsa?
- Your Clayton uniform came today.
I hung it in your closet to
get rid of that factory smell.
But it is adorable.
It just looks smart.
So, what do you two think of the roast?
Just for fun I tried a new
pre-packaged spice mix.
- Cheater.
- Why did you change the spice mix?
Also, Elsa, you carved it weird.
Dad carves it better,
when is he coming back?
Do we call him Doug?
- No, we're still Mom and Dad.
- Yeah that's a good question.
When is Dad coming home?
- Well, he's at Grandpa's
building the porch.
So, whenever that's done.
- Well, I guess that's good
that he's building a home
instead of wrecking one.
- Who wants more carrots?
- Hard pass.
- Going for a run.
- Hey you two.
You look cozy.
- What?
- I'm just coming in to see
if anyone wanted a snack
or something to drink?
- We're good actually.
- Oh no, that blazer is a little big.
You should let me tailor it.
- No thanks.
- I'll just take it in a smidge.
- Please don't.
- Just a skoush.
- Bye lady.
- Yeah, get out of here.
Sorry, sorry.
(soft music)
(thudding)
(frustrated exhaling)
(hip hop music)
(grunts)
- Huh?
(hip hop music)
- Great, now there's two of you.
- Mom?
(hip hop music)
- Oh good, you're up.
We have a lot to talk about young lady.
(hip hop music)
♪ What I know, I know ♪
- Arlo is such a shitbag!
- Casey.
- No she's right, that kid is a shitbag.
- Shitbag or not,
oh it does feel gross
to say that out loud.
- I find it invigorating, shitbag.
- We have to handle this calmly.
- Okay, well, I am gonna
calmly go over to his house and
bash his little pea head in with a shovel.
(gentle music)
- Mom?
- I was going to write screw
you bitches on the toes,
but I wasn't sure there'd be enough room.
I hope they fit.
(gentle music)
- Feast your eyes, my
official Denton student ID.
You can now call me
Denton Student 9783210.
- Aww, honey.
- Look at that smile.
- This is so exciting.
- Yeah it is.
- Casey, take a picture of us.
- Okay, No reason I should be in it,
as a member of this family.
Beautiful.
- Honey why aren't you eating?
- I have a stomach ache.
- Oh, I see.
- What do you see?
Why are you saying it like that?
- Nothing, it's just that
ever since you were little,
whenever you get stressed about something
you get a tummy ache.
First dance recital, tummy ache.
Kindergarten spelling bee, tummy ache.
First ever track meet, you
guessed it folks, tummy ache.
- Can someone pass the peas please?
- I'm just saying as someone who has known
your tummy since it was
born, it's a pattern.
- Can I borrow these
because there's a noise
in here that's bothering me.
- No.
- Yeah, I just need them for a sec.
Come on we share stuff.
- These are mine!
- Come on.
Carry on.
- I'm going to go find a doctor
to see when we can get out of here, okay?
- Ya know, no one really knows
what causes appendicitis.
- Stop.
- So technically, it could
very well still be stress.
- Stop.
- Feeling torn between
two people, perhaps?
- Nurse, this lady banged a bartender!
- School called.
You punched a milkshake?
- Um no, I didn't punch it, I bopped it.
(clattering)
(flittering)
Like that.
(yells)
- Casey!
- Ooh, that always makes a
bigger mess than I think it will.
- Hey, what's going on?
- Casey punched a milkshake and my folder.
- I'm living in the dorms.
- Yeah?
Wow, I loved living in the dorm.
What do you mean punched a milkshake?
- You have to stop punching things.
- I agree.
- Oh, do you?
Because someone punched
a hole in the wall.
Maybe we can hang a Merry Christmas sign
on Nate's milkshake.
'Kay, bye.
- Yeah, you better ''Kay, bye.'
- You're trying not to, but
you're smiling so big right now.
- No, I'm not.
Hey, Casey.
It was sweet of you to go to
Denton with your brother today.
- I have no idea what
you're talking about.
- I get it, you just had to help.
You know, you're not as different
from me as you'd like to believe.
- That is the meanest thing
you've ever said to me.
And I'm not above bopping that tea.
- Oh, I know you're not.
- Why are we here?
- I know, I'm a monster.
If I'm feeling really evil,
I'll take you to a fancy lunch after.
How are you feeling honey?
- Not bad for a heartless garbage person.
- I know, breakups are so hard.
You made a kind and brave choice.
I'd like to think I'd make that choice,
but we both know I'm not that strong.
- Mom.
I mean it does really suck.
And maybe it was the right thing to do,
but I just can't get him out of my head.
It sucks.
- [Elsa] I know it does.
I may have something to
make you feel better.
Check it out, Casey rocks!
For your track meet!
This is gonna look great
in fingerless gloves?
- [Casey] Nothing looks
good in fingerless gloves.
- [Elsa] Uh huh, Casey rocks!
- [Casey] Oh my god.
- [Elsa] Casey Rocks!
- [Casey] Calm down!
- [Elsa] Woo-woo!